che cosa ci fate qua dentro nella nostra
tenda Quelli sono soldi €500 Oh sono
nostri Vai vai ma che cos'è questo
schifo Questa sarebbe una
tenda cosa è quello Oh oh ma questa non
è la realtà virtuale questa è la realtà
reale Benvenuti su Anita Stories Io sono
Anita e io sono Ginny e oggi nuovissima
Challenge campeggio con la tenda da 10
contro tenda da €100 contro tenda da
€1000 e la nostra è la tenda media
quella da €100 e ora iniziamo subito il
tour ma prima di iniziare Volevo dirvi
che ora è disponibile il mio nuovo libro
La città stregata è ora disponibile
online e in libreria e questa è la
nostra tenda la tenda media
[Musica]
Sì E questo è il nostro tavolino con le
sedie in cui possiamo mangiare giocare
chissà come sono le tende degli altri
Già ma adesso Noi leggiamo il mio
libro cinc cara inauguriamo la nostra
tenda da €1000 che adesso è stata anche
messa in candidatura come Ottava
Meraviglia del mondo antico e moderno
alla ricchezza caro
Sal Io sono Charlotte e io sono William
e oggi vi faremo fare un giro in
esclusiva nella nostra tenda da €1000
Questo è il salotto questi sono dei
fiori raccolti direttamente dal giardino
della Regina Elisabetta da
wm qua abbiamo la mia zona guardaroba
questi due vestiti sono stati creati da
un famosissimo stilista di Milano che ha
creato questi vestiti su misura per me
questa è la nostra zona gaming
accessoriate di tutto ovviamente anche
divisore VR con ultima generazione di
intelligenza artificiale inclusa un
prototipo non ancora sul commercio che
solo noi ricchi possiamo
permetterci Questa è la zona gioielli
dove conserviamo tutti i nostri oggetti
preziosi e A proposito Charlotte vuoi
prendere questo
anello due carati io ne voglio almeno
cinque Che schifo hai ragione Non c'
avevo pensato Vabbè Vorrà dire che
domani te ne comprerò uno da 30 Carati
meglio E per finire questo è il nostro
spazio esterno accessoriato di questo
iOS isimo tavolo direttamente dalla
Reggia di
versa Che bello essere
[Musica]
ricchi Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita hai
già cliccato mi piace Se non hai ancora
cliccato mi piace Clicca subito mi piace
qua sotto e se questo video raggiunge i
10.000 mi piace faremo un nuovo video di
tende da campeggio ma faremo tenda da
campeggio da €1 contro tenda da
campeggio da €10 contro tenda da
campeggio da €10.000
Clicca subito mi piace qua sotto e ora
torniamo subito al video Io sono Billy e
io sono Frank e questa è la nostra tenda
da
€10 Sì lo so che fa schifo perché fa
proprio schifo Ehi guarda che per
comprare questa io ciho venduto i pezzi
della mia
maglietta
guarda sembri più povero di prima ma
Ho un'idea perché non andiamo a rubare
una tenda da qualcun altro Sì
andiamo Ciao Anita Ciao Ginny vogliamo
vedere la vostra tenda possiamo per
favore E per quale motivo volete
visitare la nostra tenda Sì infatti per
quale motivo
eh Perché Perché Perché la nostra è
bellissima come la nostra tenda non ce
n'è nessuna e volevamo vedere se anche
la vostra tenda Era all'altezza di un
bel campeggio Esatto Bravo Giusto Quindi
possiamo E va bene date pure un'occhiata
ma non toccate niente Sì infatti anche
perché non c'è niente Abbiamo solo due
cuscini Guarda Oddio i cuscini no non ce
l'abbiamo questi Oh ma è fantastico È
comodissimo è 10 volte meglio della
nostra 10 almeno
100 la nostra non è neanche coperta è
trasparente la
nostra dobbiamo riuscire a impadronirti
Ma come possiamo fare Ho un'idea E se
chiediamo di scambiarla con la nostra oh
questa è una buona idea Anita gy Abbiamo
una proposta da farvi E quale sarebbe
questa proposta Sì infatti sentiamo Beh
pensavamo di fare uno scambio con voi la
nostra tenda per la vostra tenda Beh per
fare questo scambio Prima dovremmo
vedere la vostra tenda è più bella della
nostra eh È più bella della vostra è più
bella della loro è molto più bella della
vostra 10 volte più bella della fostra
No no no 100 volte più bella fidatevi
non c'è bisogno di andare a vederla
fidatevi
no Senza vedere la tenda non la
scambiamo Esatto quindi andiamo subito a
vederla
dai oh oh Abbiamo un problema adesso
quando loro vedranno la nostra tenda non
vorranno più fare lo scambio Come posso
fare il libro di
[Musica]
Anita
Tad Questa è la vostra tenda che
schifo avete detto che era molto più
bella della nostra e lo è e lo è Vedi
questa è un'esperienza di totale natura
è bellissimo questo è il vero campeggio
questo è un pezzo esclusivo è fatto solo
per immergervi nella natura in mezzo a
tutte gli insetti favolosi che ci vivono
dentro Esatto quello che ha detto lui Eh
che schifo c'è una
cavalletta mi dispiace ma la vostra
tenda è molto molto più brutta della
nostra non la scambieremo mai e ora ce
ne torniamo nella nostra tenda Ciao
Ah non siamo riusciti a fare lo scambio
della tenda non vuole nessuno questa
schifezza fa troppo
schifo però ho sentito che c'è una tenda
ancora più ricca proprio di lusso una
tenda di lusso io non l'ho mai vista
Andiamo a vederla sì andiamo
Andiamo veramente pensavano che avremmo
scambiato la nostra tenda media in cui
ci si può anche sdraiare dentro con
quella tenda bruttissima ci volevano
fregare Ma non sanno che noi siamo
troppo
intelligenti
[Musica]
aspetta Dov'è il
libro
oh è
bellissima è più che bellissima è
stratosferica È incredibile sembra un
castello Ma cosa castello è 10 volte
meglio di un
castello Non ci resta che suonare Vado
Vai
Billy Oh cara ha suonato il campanello
vedere chi
è Ma chi sono questi E come son vestiti
poveracci eh chi siete Eh siamo i vostri
vicini Billy e Frank Sì volevamo
solamente vedere questa quest'opera
d'arte questa vostra tenda bellissima
possiamo m Beh che dici li facciamo
entrare Ma certo è il nostro modo per
fargli vedere tutto quello che abbiamo è
vantarci Noi amiamo vantarci
prego prego Entrate Grazie siete
gentilissimi non ho mai visto persone
gentili come voi entrate da questa parte
Grazie
grazie Ma guarda quanto spazio che c'è
qui posso anche saltare Sì ma non
saltate troppo per favore va bene ma
quello è un visore Ah sì Questo è il
nostro visore di ultima generazione con
l'intelligenza artificiale incorporata
ovviamente solo noi ricchi possiamo
permettercelo
quella è una poltrona in una tenda da
campeggio Sì esatto Ed è tutta mia è una
poltrona molto speciale perché è fatta
con materiali importati direttamente
dall'Oriente Ma è bellissima questa
tenda è stupenda Mi sono innamorato di
questo posto Ho un'idea
eh Vi vogliamo proporre uno scambio fra
tende esatto che dite Facciamo scambio
la vostra tenda con la nostra tenda uno
scambio Beh per scambiarla con questa ne
Vorremmo una almeno da un milione di
euro e deve avere pure l'aria
condizionata le cerniere oro Ovviamente
un milione di euro Non lo so se r Vale
però è ariata arieggiata è molto
arieggiata Sì sì andiamo Andiamo a
vederla andiamo andiamo eh Prego prego
ragazzi Eccomi nella nostra umile dimora
dov'è la tenda Dov'è dov'è È questa
questa
Ma che cos'è questo schifo Questa
sarebbe una tenda è un oltraggio alla
nostra ricchezza è piena di insetti mi
sto sentendo male solo a guardarla Che
schifo voi avete chiesto l'aria
condizionata Guardate
[Musica]
questo Sì questo è un macchinario di
ultima generazione bravissimo G abbiamo
convinti io non ci farei neanche dormire
una banconota da €5 Vediamo se almeno il
materiale è
degno Che schifo S Lao ad non mi sento
ben siete patetici Noi Adesso torniamo
nella nostra tenda troppa povertà
Oh non riusciamo a scambiare questa
schifezza di Tenda Billy Non ti
preoccupare non tutto è perduto se non
possiamo scambiare la nostra tenda
possiamo rubarla Guarda cosa ho qui Oh
ma questo è il libro di Anita Esatto E
sai cosa ci possiamo fare con questo
leggerlo Ma no non possiamo usare come
esca per per Anita e Ginny e poi per
rubargli la loro tenda oh oh questa è
una bella idea e
andiamo Anita Lo guidò fino alla porta e
solo all'ultimo la spalancò una luce
bianchissima quasi accecante si riversò
nel corridoio eh Ciao ragazze ancora voi
che cosa volete non la scambiamo la
tenda in realtà siamo qui solamente per
dirvi che abbiamo trovato il vostro
libro esatto nella nostra tenda l'avete
lasciato lì quando siete venuti a
vedere Ecco perché non trovavamo più la
mia copia del libro Che strano e pure io
mi ricordo che non l'abbiamo lasciata lì
vabbè andiamo a vedere
andiamo Sì è lì è proprio lì
sì corri entr
vai vai vai vai
vai e adesso chiudiamo e questa è appena
diventata la nostra tenda e possiamo
pure giocare
così Eccolo era è un po' strano che era
qua nella loro tenda devo seriamente
mettere la mano lì Vabbè di tutto per il
libro
Eccolo l'ho recuperato ora finalmente
abbiamo di nuovo i nostri due libri
e dove sono finiti Billy e
[Musica]
Frank che cosa ci fate qua dentro nella
nostra tenda Ci avete rubato la tenda
non è giusto e invece adesso questa
tenda è nostra peggio per voi che siete
cadute nella nostra
trappola e sta anche per iniziare
piovere quindi dovrete andare per forza
nella nostra tenda e tanto mi bagnerete
lo stesso perché non c'è nulla
sopra Oh no non ci credo ci siamo fatte
fregare adesso non abbiamo più la nostra
tenda dobbiamo per forza andare nella
loro tenda dei poveri io non ci entro là
dentro preferisco ripararmi sotto un
albero no prendi
questo Vabbè basta basta basta non è più
così divertente Se solo avessimo quel
bellissimo isimo visore Sì già il visore
della tenda dei Ricchi e se andassimo a
rubare la tenda dei Ricchi È un'idea
fantastica Ma Eh sì come facciamo Beh ho
un'idea possiamo usare questi come
trappola per i ricchi Ma scusa ma con
quelli ci potevamo coprire direttamente
la tenda Ah sono finti
[Musica]
Ah sei pronto sto per iniziare un grande
piano Ehi Ma quelli sono soldi 500 Oh
sono nostri Vai continua
ancora prendiamoli tutti me è mio questo
mio il prossimo è
mia Sono Anita e
Gin Cosa ci fate qui che cosa ci fate
voi Qua Infatti non vi allontanate mai
dalla tenda Beh siamo stati distratti da
alcune cose
queste banconote finte sono finte Come
abbiamo fatto a non riconoscerle anche
voi siete caduti nella Trappola
di Billy e
Frank hanno rubato la vostra tenda hanno
rubato la nostra tenda perché non ci
uniamo e troviamo un modo di sbarazzarci
dei bulli Billy e Frank sì è proprio
quello che Si meriterebbero dobbiamo
sbarazzarci di loro dei soldi finti a
dei Ricchi Ma come si permettono Sì ma
come E come facciamo a farli allontanare
dalla tenda Ehi ragazzi Io ho
un'idea adesso questa tenda da Ricky è
nostra abbiamo raggiunto il massimo
siamo noi ricchi anche se non sembro
Però ora che son ricco inventerò una
nuova moda tutti dovranno essere con la
maglietta strappata Sì sì lo puoi fare
perché tanto Sei tu che comandi sì ricco
e anche io sono ricco e posso fare
quello che voglio io posso per esempio
fare così oh io posso fare
così poi ci abbiamo i cuscini e cuscini
ancora più belli di quelli lotta con i
cuscini lotta con i cuscini qua qua
Basta lotta con i cuccini possiamo
prendere il pezzo forte sì quale la
poltrona ma no il visore che bello
questo gioco È bellissimo sembra quasi
di picchiare un modulo oh oh ma questa
non è la realtà virtuale Questa è una
realtà
reale Quanto è bello questo
gioco
Ah bellissimo sì
[Musica]
vai cosa è quello un gorilla sì è
proprio un gorilla e io lo sto
sconfiggendo No non hai capito È un vero
gorilla Ok Ragazzi Pronti Via Ehi ma che
cosa sta succedendo c'è un terremoto e
un gorilla e l'apocalisse Oh è colpa di
questa tenda da Ricky scappa scappa
FZ
Cor Corri corri ce l'abbiamo fatta con
il nostro piano abbiamo allontanato i
bulli Sì è stato un piano perfetto anche
se adesso ci vorrà un po' per mettere a
posto la tenda Però ne valsa la pena li
ho spaventati tantissimo con il mio
costume e ora parti nella tenda dei
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ricchi
n